[Applause]
hello everyone good morning I wanna also
I don't know if you saw Jacob in the
video the guy with the black mustache
he's not here he just had a baby two
weeks ago so congratulations to him he
asked me to come and give this keynote
and then he doesn't show up it
apparently his priorities are elsewhere
anyway welcome to the NDC welcome to the
Machine now how many of you are Pink
Floyd fans yeah okay so this has got
nothing to do with Pink Floyd but if you
are paying for a fan like me this was a
also a track from their album wish you
were here back in 1975 which was two
years after I was born and oh god I'm
old anyway and we'll talk about that a
little bit and it has what what exactly
is a machine but I want to start with
something else which actually also
references a song by Roger Waters
amusing ourselves to death now that's
not about Roger Walters that's about a
gentleman called Neil postman any of you
heard of this one so he wrote a book
back in 1985 and he was talking about
how initially with the telegram and then
with the radio and then with with TV we
started to get a whole bunch of
information we started to get
information about things that weren't
really impacting directly our lives and
this was enabled further and further as
we came along and essentially what was
happening is that things that were
relevant were getting lost in
irrelevance because there was so much
information that was coming you know
back in the old days like things that
wouldn't impact me today I was hearing
about right like a kangaroo escaped from
the zoo in Sydney like that was
front-page news
right not not that it would impact me
but anyway and of course information
needed to be entertaining
specially promoted with this idea of TV
right because it was this amazing thing
that gave you visual arts and people not
only had to inform you but they had to
entertain you it wasn't like the radio
where people just talking this was like
entertain
engagement you know it was kind of like
acting in a sense what it was acting and
what he said about the television he
said that it's altering the meaning of
being informed by creating a species of
information that might properly be
called disinformation this information
does not mean false information it means
misleading information misplaced
irrelevant fragmented or superficial
information information that creates the
illusion of knowing something but which
in fact leads one away from knowing now
this was talking about back in the days
of TV right there was another book also
anybody read this book a brave new world
does this was written by Aldous Huxley
in 1931 and in it he was describing this
futuristic dystopia where we had like a
controlled population with artificial
procreation we had psychological
manipulation we had a continuous use of
substances for entertainment back in
1931 right and in relation to amusing
ourselves to death and what Neil postman
was saying and this is like the second
thing that I'll probably read here is
that he said what oh well feared were
those who would ban books what Huxley
feared was that there would be no reason
to ban a book for there would be no one
who wanted to read one what Orwell
feared were those that would deprive us
of information Huxley feared those who
would give us so much information that
would be reduced to passivity and egoism
Orwell feared that the truth would be
concealed from us Huxley feared the
truth would be drowned in a sea of
irrelevance over all over all feared we
would become a captive culture Huxley
feared we would become a trivial culture
preoccupied with some equivalent of the
Feelies the orgy Porgy and the
centrifugal bumble-puppy which I have no
idea what it is but and what Neal was
saying was that in short he feared you
know Orwell feared that we what we hate
will ruin us Huxley feared what we loved
will ruin us and his book was that maybe
it was Huxley that was right and not all
well right and all of this bored about
by TV right
we're glued to
TV you know like Bruce Springsteen's 57
channels and nothing on all just
entertainment trying to get us attention
and of course that's in the past because
then came along this amazing thing
called the internet right and the
internet I don't know if anybody's old
enough to remember what that was that's
that's a modem back in the old days okay
no more war game No
so we came along with the internet which
obviously said oh well take away the TV
now we've got this amazing medium which
is fantastic and amongst other things
you know the printed media said well we
needed to survive in this era right so
we start to promote our newspapers
online and we've got to make them very
engaging and we're gonna make them
wonderful I'm gonna make these headlines
so that people come and read our papers
but of course they even saw a bigger
opportunity right because they're like
well we can actually make money off of
this cuz no one's gonna pay us to read
the news like those days of printing
something in people paying for it have
gone now we've got to make money solely
off advertising which was great right I
mean it works you know you had a little
corner there you had some advertising in
the corner they called it revenue we
called it annoying banners right and I'm
from Spain and in Spain when something
comes out in from a technological
perspective or whatever we want to take
it to the next limit we really want to
push it right this is my newspaper in
Spain somewhere in the middle there you
can see an actual headline right
everything else is essentially banners
my local paper takes it even further and
as I scroll it Scrolls the banners with
me right so I do like that top one there
is scrolling with me so I don't get to
see any of it what I do right because I
use an ad blocker but if anyone else
watches it that's what they see but it's
great right because it was revenue was a
way to get it so what did we do we
install the ad blockers yep how many of
you here use an ad blocker exactly there
you go and what did the paper's do
they're like oh no listen we've noticed
that you've given stalled an ad blocker
and it's it's you know we need to
support ourselves what we what did we do
we're like no way I'm gonna fire out the
chrome tools
and I'm gonna get rid of that div cuz
I'm gonna read that bloody paper and
you're not gonna stop me right and you
spend like six hours trying to do this
you know which you could pay for the
paper but don't pay screw that no
anyway so and of course many people took
the route of native advertising how many
of you here have heard of the term
native advertising it's been around
actually for a very very long time and
the idea of native advertising is
instead of me putting like banners I
would kind of bend in right
I would blend in somehow with with the
news otherwise known as content
marketing in the technical era right so
for example you see here this is the
Guardian and you can see a little
section at the top there that shows you
like you know a paid content now I know
this because I I see this right often
it's a little bit more subtle but
there's always like a paid by or a
Outbrain or whatever in the corner
somewhere so it's like the disclaimer
that this is an advertising anything oh
what's the big deal right well I mean
you know I want to read an article about
how much do you know about vagin food
which sounds fantastic right then I
start to read it and it says oh you know
actually vagin food is really really bad
for you and going begging is wrong and
you're like oh this must be like really
you know important I maybe should no
longer become a vagrant and then you
like if you follow the links you're like
oh
sponsored by someone that works at a
company called meats R Us
yes so you know it it's a Content that
blends in but then you don't know behind
the scenes who's paying for this or what
their intentions are so a lot of
companies papers now if you notice
they've got this concept of native
advertising and of course some of us may
double-check other people say oh no this
is facts right this is news it's on the
news website that's it it's just an
article there and it's that but there
was an even greater opportunity here
which was called targeted advertising
right and allowing you to basically
track people you've all done it you know
you've likely you've googled oh you've
gone to Amazon or whatever and even look
for a fridge and then you've ended up
buying that fridge but then for the next
six months you know the ads are
following you saying do you want a
fridge right did they kind of like
target you in that sense and it was
allowing to track people right they
called it personal experience otherwise
known as personal manipulation
because back in the old days you know
when you had a billboard you had a TV an
advert of like say whatever a drink or
whatever it was blasting out to everyone
right whether you were the demographics
they were targeting or not it was
blasting out now with tracking and
targeted advertising it is finding a
specific demographic and targeting those
people so it's specifically targeted at
manipulating in a sense those people
because at the end of the day you know
advertising is essentially manipulation
of emotions but we said enough of that
it's over enough is enough and now came
GDP our right and what did we get with
that we got more pop ups a lot more pop
ups it's also funny people have come
from the states and they're like what is
good what's going wrong with the world
wide web in Europe yeah it's called GDP
R and you get interesting articles that
talk about the importance of privacy by
first displaying a pop up saying how
their privacy is important to you and
please accept all and then we'll we'll
track everything right some song some
people in the in outside of Europe
they're kind of like oh you know to hell
with the EU we're not even going to
serve the EU anymore right we're just
kind of like stopped serving Europe and
obviously this is even wrong because
it's targeting European people not where
your location is but that's that's what
GDP are has has given us more pop-ups
and all of this of course is information
for our attention yearning for us to be
able to read something that's
entertaining competing for our short
tiny little attention span it's like
I've only got two minutes to browse the
web and then how the hell did I end up
looking at this YouTube video why am I
even here oh my god it's been six hours
that short attention span we all have
it's all yearning for it hopefully that
we click on those ads now of course some
of us some some of them are now moving
towards a paid model which is which is
also interesting because you get you're
kind of like now paying and get the
advertising like and it depends on then
on them paper like for example The
Guardian or many papers that currently
say support us right please donate
to support us to continue to provide you
with independent news you have other
ones The Telegraph actually started very
interesting initially it was like you
can read five articles and then it was
now everything is premium and you can
only read one article that's free and
it's basically moved towards a paid
model independent for example props up
this banner that says you know pay to
help support us
I especially find this one interesting
because if you scroll further down
there's another banner that comes up
that says support free thinking
journalism right so it's saying
essentially either support us to get
free thinking journalism or remove your
ad blocker and get the adverts which
kind of makes you think so
what am I getting if I'm looking at the
ads is it is it an added version of your
journalism or is it how does that
exactly work but anyway more and more
people are essentially moving towards
this paid model but you say well it
doesn't matter
I mean traditional media is essentially
a thing of the past right I mean that in
nowadays this whole idea of traditional
newspapers and journalists and all of
that that's that's really a thing of the
past it's all about social media now
right because in fact social media is
feeding the media right how many times
have you seen that something's happened
and someone's tweeted something or
there's been like some video and all of
the you know all of the media are like
oh this is CBS 10 for 7 station 259
could we please use your video and the
person's like yes and then at some point
there's always like the Daily Mail could
we use this and everyone's badging oh no
no no no don't let those bloody monsters
use your video right we see this day in
and day out on on social media people
are tweeting information and the
journalists are picking up on this and
using that as their source of media
right essentially we've all of us become
micro journalists in a sense right
that's one good thing that came out of
micro-services it's given everyone
essentially a voice and what is it given
us information overload right so before
we had the TV now we've got the internet
now we've got the media now we've got
social media all of this data coming at
us and this normally comes in the shape
of different formats right we
Twitter anyone heard of Twitter right
there's another one which starts with an
F snapchat I don't know if that that's
about disappearing messages it's still
around I think it is go around and
Google+ which isn't that that was a very
very small group in fact they shot it
down and nobody was upset except my
mother and she like calls me she's like
they're closing Google+ I'm like yeah
and she's like I'm on Google+ I'm like
but it's only you like it's okay yeah or
not no one's gonna miss you who you know
I mean I I mean you I'm
blessed my mother she follows me on
Twitter and she hits like on these
technical posts I'm like do you don't
even know what that means but anyway so
but you know Google+ anyway I was
another good attempt but we've created
our walled gardens right we've
essentially created this curated
environment in which each of us are on
all of these different platforms where
we follow like-minded people right
because we want to stick to our tribes
we block those we don't agree with more
and more I hear oh I've blocked this
word oh I've blocked that person oh I've
blocked him or blocked her or I block
this I blocked that you know not to
alter our our way of thought and we
essentially are in our own echo chambers
inside our different walled gardens and
who's our keeper well the platform is
our keeper right there our keeper here
so they create content that matters to
us right how many times you've heard
just recently Twitter top tweets first
based on what oh no here's your top
tweets your your home feed on Facebook
here's the interesting news that matters
to you said who I did how do you know
well we'll figure that out later but
here's what you need to see first right
things that you care more about first
all of this being pushed towards us then
we trust this keeper right and we help
the keeper we hit like we like oh I like
this post like like like like the other
day there was an article about how life
is destroying the internet and I said I
agree so I was like no no no no I don't
use like when I like something
I'm like what what do you use it for to
bookmark something all right do you
realize that the essential issue here
that we're semantically not interpreting
the word the same way for one people for
some people it's like for you it's just
a bookmark but that actually has an
impact because that's feeding many
things that's feeding people that think
that because you like something they're
endorsing it that's feeding the
algorithms thinking you're liking
something we hit this life I I
especially like the dislike one and and
the way the world is going with the
emotions in like disgust now provides
you with a platform with a whole bunch
of different emotions which is fantastic
right there's like you write a blog post
and there are emotions that you can add
saying I hate it you know screw you this
is disgusting and we've we put that all
into emojis which is fantastic right we
hit share share is brilliant like it's
so easy to just share it's excellent
awesome to get our content out there and
all of this of course is feeding those
algorithms right and these algorithms
what are they focused on they're focused
on engaging people they want to be you
to be on their platform as much as
possible so they're focused on engaging
how do they do that by targeting people
and engaging them with different
activities but there's also things that
you may see or may not see or I may see
and you may not see and we don't often
hear about that now this one we did hear
about for instance this was about a
picture of Vietnam that was banned by
Facebook and it got picked up by a
Norwegian magazine and said this is
ridiculous why are you banning this and
Facebook came out and said oh sorry it
was a mistake right it says mistake that
I've been banning this type of pictures
and there's multiple examples of this
and at some point they actually in gay
released their rules of censorship so to
speak right and in it there were things
like you know us remarks such as someone
shoot Trump should be deleted because as
a head of state he's in a protected
category but it can be permissible to
say to snap a neck make sure to
apply all your pressure to the middle of
her throat because they are not regarded
as credible threats it is
videos of violent deaths while
disturbing do not always have to be
deleted because they can create help
awareness of issues such as mental
illness so there's a rulebook apparently
somewhere that someone is following and
telling us what should and shouldn't be
censored for good and bad and of course
we don't even think about the human side
of this right which is essentially
censor shops in Philippines and many
places in the world have become the new
equivalent of sweatshops where you have
low paid people being paid very low
salaries to sit and censor information
that might affect some others such as us
right leading them to anxiety to
depression too many things examples
there was literally nothing enjoyable
about the job you'd going to work at
9:00 a.m. every morning turn on your
computer and watch someone have their
head cut off every day every minute
that's what you see heads being cut off
all that so that we can enjoy our little
pictures of puppies and cats right
someone else is taking care of that and
eventually algorithms will take care of
that but they might also censor the
wrong things right
so that also those lead the question of
do I actually see everything water is
being censored that I don't know what is
not in my feet what is things in my feet
that may not be in other people's feet
but our feet are bite-sized information
that we can easily share it's it's
become so easy to share right oh my god
I created this
this is the definitive proof that the
earth is flat the article is
mind-blowing now this is stupid right
well okay so for some people it's not
but anyway this is stupid but there
could be an article that's not so
controversial it might be a little bit
controversial what is the normal share
flow in this case right the
dissemination of information it's let's
see the person is someone I really trust
or generally trust yes I follow them
I've trusted them
I skimmed the article yeah I looked
through it that was like six paragraphs
it's okay there were paragraphs in there
the message kind of aligns with my
thoughts
confirmation bias I'll share and maybe
read it later in more detail and we just
hit share just like that what we
generally don't do is say okay let me
see let me see if it's fake or not let
me read the article in detail and
contrast it with other sources no let me
see the entire video of that short clip
that highlights a specific point maybe
to fit the narrative no let me put the
voice snippet or quote into the bigger
context no in fact just just the other
day there was a discussion something
about the web and Brendan Eich had a
like a tweet in there somewhere that
says I admit JavaScript was a mistake I
snapshot it dad and I said there you go
Brendan Eich says the JavaScript was a
mistake so don't blame me when I said it
as well right taking things out of
context let me read the comments on that
tweet post like I will tweet something
and before retweeting it actually let me
look through the comments and see if
there is anything fake or not just
recently there was a video of the there
was a strong winds or I don't know what
it was somewhere in the Philippines or
wherever and some guy that is I don't
know one of these shows a big brother or
what what have you Scott like 300,000
followers on Twitter verified account
which means he's somebody I guess and he
had tweeted this video of this airplane
going like this like a big 747 going
like this twirling and then suddenly
pictures of people rushing off the plane
and he's like oh my god that was amazing
piloting I'm like you realize that I
mean even if you're not
Miller with the laws of aerodynamics
this is completely fake and people are
calling it out for him and he actually
believed that that was real and he's
like okay well fine it was fake okay
well next time I'll check but the
problem is that that initial tweet gets
like six hundred thousand shares the
correction gets zero and people are like
oh my god what amazing piloting he
that's better than Captain Sully you
know we don't even read those in fact
like by the way my sampling is really
really bad right and that when I when I
tweet a poll I only get like 50 people
answering but hey it's great for my
narrative and it says you know when you
have something controversial how much
how many times do you actually contrast
that information between retweeting it
kind of like not everyone does but you
say but I don't have time I gotta watch
videos of cats I can't do this all the
time no of course we don't have time
what we can do is we can basically share
and forget and the web has made it so
much easier for us to essentially do
that and we share things are many many
topics right we share things on
companies and organizations we share
information about individuals we share
information about politics I don't know
if any of you have seen this the 29
stages of a Twitter storm right it's uh
so essentially the company does
something wrong someone catches wind
makes the rounds famous person makes a
comment on it like oh my god I can't
believe you did this media notices it
picks it up company forced to apologize
everyone forgets and moves on to
tomorrow
like literally that is about it's become
every 24 hours there is some Twitter
storm going on on the web around some
topic a lot of information we don't have
time to analyze everything but you say
what this is good
will show these bloody corporations
right we will show with our wallet will
show with our voice if they're doing
something wrong we'll call them out for
it and it's good I'm not saying it's bad
it is good but not everything is that
simple not everything is because there
are also the aspects of individuals now
how many of you remember this story lady
called justine sacco now justine sacco
was a lady a few years ago
was working as a head of communications
for large corporation and she was
getting on a plane from Heathrow said
I'm heading to South Africa hope I don't
catch AIDS
just kidding I'm white right so she took
off eight hours later landed she was
trending topic worldwide shorts took to
sum up the long story
she was ruined right she was she was
dark she was kicked out of the job she
was smashed to she was living for years
and years and years on sofas of people
not being able to get a job a whole
bunch of things right and Wired magazine
I think the New York Post also
interviewed her and of course you know
the only person that truly knows whether
that was sarcasm or not is her the only
person that truly knows whether that's
something you should even joke about or
not well it's for her to decide I'm not
judging anything here but my point is
that everyone remembered that this woman
made a mistake or whatever and it was
destroyed and everyone forgot but her
life wasn't the same right now I think I
actually looked her up recently and I
think she's actually gone back to work
for one of the subsidiaries of the
original company right after like four
or five years but the point is here that
when we have so much information and
we're not able to contrast everything
and we don't know the insights and we
don't know everything it becomes a
little bit you know you've got to start
to take a little bit of caution here
because it's not just just sharing
something because what happens with all
the stories that we haven't followed up
on what about all those things that
happen to people that we haven't
followed up on to see what's happened
but what has happened is a social media
has basically made it as judge jury and
executioner it's enabled us to do that
we judge things without having deep
inside we condemn people everything very
very easily and every retweet every
share every whatever every stop tweeting
every quote all of these things are
contributing on this right
so I don't know if you're familiar with
the film 1984 but there was a segment
which was called the two minutes of hate
where people would just go and hate for
two minutes on something right the party
was telling them to hate someone or
something it often feels like that's
what social media is enabled right
just to hate for two minutes and then
move on to something else so but there
are also things that have much greater
impact right there's there's things that
can impact I mean just call our
companies for bad behavior call our
people for bad behavior all of these
things are acceptable and they can drive
us in a better direction in society but
there's also things that have bigger
impact there is violence right this idea
of sharing and sharing things and rumors
etc can lead to violence on whatsapp in
India several people innocent people
were killed because rumors were
incorrectly accusing certain people of
doing something wrong right that leads
to violence if you don't know about it
if you don't contrast and you just
blindly share it's just accumulating
that it's just adding to it people set
on fire because of rumors etc and then
of course we know the politics of this
right the politics now a few years ago
this talk was actually based off of
another talk where I which I did a few
years ago which was called where was my
free lunch and back when cambridge
analytical is a thing i was talking
about this thing that I had read
regarding this company that Cambridge
analytic on nowadays everybody knows I
mean is there anybody in the room that
doesn't know what Cambridge analytic
guys and if you don't know you'll
probably see it shortly in a movie
that's coming up and that this other
topic that's going on in the UK right
now I can't recall so you know but it
doesn't make you it begs you you know
it's kind of like said so if we can
target someone with a washing machine
like why can't we target them for voting
for something it's like whoa I didn't
think of that
really so instead of selling them a
device I can sell them our idea
mind-blowing like really are we shocked
that this happened
are we like Cambridge analytical is what
did they do what did they do you know
it's like oh okay and if we can target
certain segments of society based on
specific characteristics well you're
saying that we can spot target specific
groups yes in fact if you do Facebook
posts it can say oh gender ethnicity
what you want to target there you go now
you group your manipulative messages
towards certain groups of society based
on gender race social status
what-have-you
anybody heard of dark posts dark posts
is the most amazing thing you can use in
advertising right there's multiple
articles about dark posts dark posts is
essentially the idea that they don't
show up as your company they don't show
up in your feet or your followers stream
they appear and disappear at random
times when you want it in someone's
feed right they avoid your content to
look spammy they're great right because
they appear at times specific groups
they allow you to mark micro target
specific groups they can say Oh target
this group and show them this post
whereas this other group show them that
post in principle it's innocent right
I'm not going to target things about you
know IntelliJ IDEA that I've written in
English to a group of people in China
because amongst other things maybe they
prefer the Chinese version right in
principle it could look innocent but the
reality is that this use for the wrong
reasons such as politics leads to some
of the issues that we see they allow you
though to do better a be testing even
with politics right and it's amended by
Facebook available on all platforms now
you can do it on all platforms it's all
great it's wonderful right and with the
marked micro targeting what we're doing
is profiling voters based on social
media and other data you know creating
tribes and what do the tribes do what do
individuals do they do word-of-mouth
marketing right have this message to
send them and they do word-of-mouth
marketing because what what works
word-of-mouth marketing if I tell you to
use IntelliJ it's not going to be the
same because I'm from JetBrains versus
if someone else says to you use IntelliJ
you're going to believe them better
right word-of-mouth marketing it works
it works for selling products it works
for anything you want
there's actually a very good talk from
this lady called Xena to feschi I don't
know if I said that right but we're
building a dystopia just to make people
click on ads I recommend you watch that
but this is what it's essentially led to
and of course we've heard about
hemorrhage on a lit cigar because of
brexit because of elections in the UK in
the u.s. whatever but this isn't a new
idea this was actually done before it
was done during the Obama administration
that was done during the Clintons to a
different extent maybe what data they
were getting what data they were not
getting but the idea was there and it's
been used to greater or less success
it's being used so you're like can
anything good come from all of this
right because like so far everything
I've shown you is bad just just to not
spoiler alert everything else I'm going
to show you is also bad right this this
isn't a very positive talk so don't get
your hopes up so actually something
recently did good did come from it there
was a lady I don't know if you heard
about this there was a lady that wanted
to be deported to Saudi Arabia back she
managed to get asylum from the Canadian
government I believe and it was because
she made a lot of noise so in essence
it's not the question that maybe social
media is bad or whatever
in essence it's what we are sharing and
how we're sharing it and the rules by
which we are sharing or allowing how
many of you remember the Arab Spring
right how many of you remember the green
avatar for Iran know many years ago I
was born in Iran so this is dear to my
heart I guess many years ago there was
this a kind of like a thing to go there
was a meme on I won't call it a meme
there was a movement on Twitter to put
your avatar green you know shaded green
to show support for the uprising of some
people in Iran against the government
right and people were doing this
everyone like you looked at your Twitter
stream everything was Green
everything was green and you were like
I'm helping support these people right
it's a good cause right I mean if you're
against you know the current regime in
Iran if you feel that it's oppressive if
you feel more
against something and you feel morally
towards a cause you could support that
cause you can show your support but
let's put let's listen for a moment step
back and think about the impact that
this may have and let's talk
hypothetically this may have happened
this may have not happened there's some
kid some woman some man someone in Iran
that is fed up with the regime and when
i say iran i can say anything any
country whatever they're fed up and they
see an outpour of support and they see
an outpour of support from people and
they're thinking to themselves all of
these people are supporting me everyone
is supporting me I should do something
about it I shouldn't just sit back maybe
this is the time for me to stand up you
know there'd ever inspiring me to stand
up and I'll go and I'll stand up and
I'll go and fight in the street and
maybe they get shot and killed or maybe
they get imprisoned right for us what
was it a green avatar for them it was
inspiring them but that inspiration did
we actually think about all of the
possible consequences that our
inspiration may lead to did we think
about that you know Neil postman in his
book talks about the passive observer in
a sense right that I don't give a crap
that there is a kangaroo that is lost in
a zoo in Sydney it's entertaining it's
not going to impact my life but we have
gone from being passive observers to
essentially armchair participants we
have now a power and a voice to
participate in things but not often do
we actually look at all the potential
outcomes and all of the consequences of
our participation but ok fair enough
forget it it's not about politics I
really do want to share cats it's about
friends and family that's what I have
you know I just like to tell take
selfies of pigs and food and I like to
just frost on my friends timelines and
see what they're up to
it helps me stay connected with friends
and family I hear that all the time
regarding Facebook I had this I'm to
prove to you I don't have a Facebook
account I deleted it like 6 years ago
but to prove to you I had something like
I don't know like 800 or 900 friends on
Facebook in real life I've got like one
OK
I was the least like kid at school so
but what about the other impacts of this
the psychological impacts of all of this
activity all of this trying to have a
presence trying to always make that
presence better right we're always kind
of like this stroll and refresh I post a
pic and I'm like oh why aren't they
getting Wyatt is why isn't it getting
enough likes well is it this retweet why
didn't this retweet go out enough is it
something I said didn't they like it did
I disagree with someone Oh what's gonna
happen if someone misinterpret it or
misquote Smee this is all anxiety that
is affecting a lot of people right and
then of course you're scrolling through
and like oh yeah that person just bought
a wonderful car or that person just
bought a wonderful husband
yeah we started in the same University
how come they get to go where they are
and I'm not right whatever human nature
different people are different right
some RMBS some are not but this is all
contributing negatively and there are
multiple studies that talk about how
depression is linked to social media
right there's multiple of them I mean
I've shown you a bunch of them and I
know unfortunately there was a recent
incident here in the UK and also about a
girl that was committed suicide which
was related somewhat to Instagram and
her activity there and this goes on
right toxicity toxicity studies have
found that is one of the most toxic
places for women twitter and all of this
happens right so it's not just about the
politics it's not just about calling our
companies and it's not just about social
media because we are ser sharing so much
data and and to be clear like this isn't
a rant about social media or platforms
it's about the data and the
misinformation and the amount of
information you want to Train there's an
app for that
you want a jog there's an app for that
you want to see how much calories you've
eaten there's an app for that
how much wine you've drunk there's an
app for that how much you've slept
there's an app for that how much you
work there's an app for that it's called
focus or multiple ones back in the old
days we used to call this discipline
what you read there's an app for that
and guess what what you watch there's an
app for that
and where you go there's an app for that
anything you could potentially think of
there's an app for right and then of
course you've got the best app of all
which is your assistance
call it Alexa Google Siri Cortana bixby
al now III they're all there
right they're all there you know if
someone has sets you five years ago hey
can I put a video camera or microphone
in your house and record everything you
say and do like what are you stupid are
you saying that if I buy one Siri I get
another one free amazing I can have this
in every room Wow
so cool well I got a big deal so I get
some targeted ads right train asleep
coated by Bruce Schneier right
surveillance is the business model of
the Internet we build systems and spy on
people in exchange for services
corporations call it marketing got my
data is meaningless it is free
alright and I get this for free I get
all of these apps for free and I just
didn't keep my data it's okay my date is
meaningless
in fact we're taking this sort of real
world there's a coffee shop now in
Boston that says hey you don't even have
to pay for your latte just give me your
data like go in there give me some data
get a latte but why free Miyoko recently
had a tweet you see he does get a lot of
thoughts he's got like $6 it's like if
Google would start charging money for
Google search would you pay for it like
get out of here pay for Google said get
out and I should get it free right so
you all know this quote I tracked it
down and parented to a gentleman called
Andrew Lewis if you're not paying for it
you're not the customer you're the
product being sold right we've heard
this multiple times I got a new coat for
you it's for me it doesn't matter
anymore whether you're paying or not
you're still the product right they're
still paying for your devices you're
still paying for those apps and you're
still the product yeah it's like now
it's not about oil it's about data right
it's big data and the best part of it is
while all will run out data probably
won't well probably yeah I mean oil will
run out just in case someone things all
won't run out it will
and of course this is getting worse also
known as the Internet of Things right
it's fantastic like you know I love this
headline LG threatens to put Wi-Fi in
every appliance it introduces in 2017 it
threatens it's like you know it's
fantastic now my fridge is talking to
Amazon I don't even have to do the
shopping
it's like he's lacking some milk okay
I'll get him some milk I'll buy some
Sawyer as well because he's been
drinking a little bit of that I don't
even need to intervene I'll get my
fridge to talk to him at Amazon or
whatever directly it's fantastic right
LG now works with Amazon and Google
assistant so in the morning I toast
bread for my kids my toast is gonna
sound insane oh you're gonna have to
transfer some Bitcoin for me to release
this toaster to you because you know as
famously or like once says that the s in
IOT stands for security so but this is
ridiculous like hmm you got that did you
okay it's like how to turn off Smart TV
snooping features like literally you
have to go into your TV and turn off the
snooping features it's like I want to
have a private conversation with my wife
I'm not sure let's get out the TV's
listening
it's no longer the kids are present no
it's the TV's presence alright let's go
out in the garden but you've got the
barbecue the new barbecue with the Wi-Fi
oh
it's like okay barbecue lighter and all
this time of course we've been focusing
on Internet of Things forgetting that
we're actually the Internet of people
like we as individuals are generating so
much data through the apps and through
the assistance and all of this that is
essentially the Internet of people of
course some people want to take this to
the next level and they like in Sweden
thousands of Swedes are inserting
microchips under their skin to
facilitate payment if this gets
implemented what they should actually do
is like have a hand that says like a
high-five and then you go to the
shopping just like high-five right yeah
and today is for payments tomorrow I've
actually got our idea for startup for
you here's what you do we all get the
microchips implanted and then when you
shake hands there's a contacts exchange
right you get each other's emails that
would work as a startup idea for you
we're moving towards it's even more data
is being generated so essentially we've
sacrificed all of our privacy for
convenience it's just so easy to do a
handshake and paying right I don't have
to get the phone out and like get the
credit card on that just top my little
phone and pay with that what questions
we don't generally ask ourselves you
know like do they store my data like do
they send it anywhere do they how can
they use my data is it safe terms of
what like what what do you want me to
read no this is an experiments by
f-secure which brand in London
giving free Wi-Fi in exchange for your
firstborn six people signed up they
discontinued it after the first six that
sign up they're like yeah maybe we'll
get into legal problems here
some people don't read the Terms of
Service who reads the Terms of Service
here especially every time you go to
Google it's like oh then you know the
Android so it's like oh 78 apps updated
would you like to update here sure do
you want to read through the Terms of
Service over seventy eight nine yeah and
every time they might change that a
little bit to get you more get less data
from you behind behind that home DNA
testing company sharing genetic data
with third parties now it was in the
Terms of Service you know you just
didn't read it it's like
why would we want to put together an
amazing database of everyone's DNA's
that's a good idea if they hack it no no
no one's gonna hack it try no one hacks
things do their
Roombas have been busy mapping our homes
and now that data could be shared right
I use an application called untapped
it's about beers so it's nice right the
idea is that every time I drink a beer I
I check in my beer so that sometime I
could go back and see how I like that
beer before I order it again which never
happens but anyway it's a good idea and
so I essentially end up competing for
badges which I'll never win anyway
because Jimmy Bogart has got all the
badges there are but anyway so I'm like
okay I've got a circle of friends that
will share the the the beers that I
drink with me
and the other day I bought this beer I
checked it and it was horrible I'm like
I go to Google and write who makes this
what does Google turn up this page I'm
like wait a minute why does it say I
drank that beer
I didn't I like I didn't say that I can
share this publicly
oh no there was a default option that
says your property your profile is
public right yet one day some some
insurance company's gonna start data
mining this and say hopefully not giving
him insurance anymore drinks too much
Jimmy this is for you
do we take time to configure these all
of these options so the other day again
I logged into LinkedIn and it says howdy
you're the boss of your account and I'm
like finally I'm the boss of something I
said okay let me try and configure this
privacy okay how are the CEO profile our
network information okay that was one
page privacy how others see your
LinkedIn activity
okay next page how LinkedIn uses your
data next page job seeking preferences
blocking and Heidi like do you seriously
think that I have time to go through
four pages of privacy settings to
configure it for you to tell me what I
can and cannot do or allow you to do
with my data and I'm not even talking
about the ads the ads had its own column
of settings right of course but being
but it's it's legal on the gdpr we're
explicitly telling you what you can
I don't do oh okay thank you thanks for
that and when it's not optional right
and when you're not told about it
multiple cases Bose headphones spying on
listeners sending it to a data mining
site that they could send it anywhere
right
the app will get the best experience out
of both oh and I'll listen to everything
you're listening to you know fiber that
makes maker to pay millions all the
claims that secretly attract users
AccuWeather code sending user location
data even when location sharing is off
over 500 Android app spying on over 100
million users
uber taking screenshots when they
shouldn't run keeper tracking you when
they shouldn't it's all there and then
of course it's when software has issues
Twitter oh yeah sorry about that a whole
bunch of direct messages private message
were actually public we we found the bug
Facebook you know oh yeah we had an
issue it defaulted to public so a whole
bunch of information is public this was
a recent one just a couple of days ago
you can basically listen to any
conversation using the FaceTime on an
iPhone without even having to for the
person to pick it up and then of course
it's what else what if someone else
accesses that data you know it's like
every freaking day I get an email from
have I been pawned thanks Troy it's like
you you should just take down that
website and just put a big yes you're
all screwed right literally you're just
you you are pawned every freaking day
you're gonna get porn around something
right
I have quote fax giving out credit card
winning information all of it and we
don't think about this I mean we can't
we're gonna both go paranoid right but
what happens if one day one of these
people use some of this data against you
and there are cases some of them hit the
media some of them don't where people
are being dogs they're being their lives
are being destroyed because someone
wants vengeance I came across a website
recently which was called family tree
now and I went through it and it's
basically going to track your hair of
heritage across your family tree this is
really big in the US and it actually
thought I'm gonna say fortunately it
only works in the u.s. because there was
a sister site to it which was called
true people search and it worked in the
US so I typed in a friend a name of mine
colleague the worker that lives in the
u.s. guess what it turned up his home
address his previous address all of his
recent telephone numbers
it's possible relatives all of this
information online accessible to anyone
now I don't know about you but in Spain
there are companies that actually ask
those questions there's security
questions I call my phone company and
I'm like I want to change my bank
account details they're like yeah give
me your current address here it is
what's your telephone number here okay
mister hurry what's the new account
number right so easy to access this
information and you're like yeah but
this is all public records sure but no
one said put it on the damn Internet
where over there you go but you say oh
I've got nothing to hide right I really
don't have anything to hide I'm a
straight person I don't like in terms of
legal I don't have anything to do I've
not done anything wrong anything illegal
it's all good
not that I'm a fan it was Snowden but he
did say that arguing that you don't care
about the right to privacy because you
have nothing to hide there's no
different than saying you don't care
about free speech because you have
nothing to say and that's pretty
accurate right all of us have something
to hide
all of us have said things about
colleagues co-workers bosses spouses
husband whatever that we have for we
prefer for it not to be public that is
what makes us humans that is what makes
us individuals our privacy well you like
our we're not lacking we're not in a
well in society now again I'm sure that
everyone's heard of 1984 which was by
George Orwell written in 1949 censorship
talks about a society of censorship
about control about Big Brother but
fortunately we don't have any of that
right prism ah that's the thing of the
past anyone remember prism here no it's
now gone the other direction now the FBI
is actually collaborating with companies
to give them real-time information
it's fantastic you can check up
everything about your employees at any
time but again you don't even need this
infrastructure you don't even need the
access to private data anymore
right all of it is on social media back
if you if you've ever gone if you ever
filled out an ester form anyone yet to
go to the US right back in the old days
it was a green card on the plane then
they said we're gonna make it more
efficient and charge you $20 for it so
that's the form back in the I think it
was like the second term of the Obama
administration they started to introduce
social media fields
right github Facebook LinkedIn I'm like
are you seriously gonna judge me based
on my github okay I swear they forced me
to use JavaScript it wasn't my choice
right but that shouldn't allow me to not
enter your country like I don't even
need this information to be private
anymore
China how many of you heard of those
citizen social credit score system in
China that's there I've been it's there
right this lady was on the tea on chain
tangent to Beijing training the
announcement said breaking the rules
will impact your credit score now think
about that just think about that for a
second that's not black mirror think
about that okay and China doubles down
on real name so you have to register
with your real identity right so it's
it's all there and in fact I actually
raise the point here about do you think
that a lot of the hate and the vitriol
that goes on in the Internet is to do
with the fact that we're anonymous that
was divided but and when with anonymous
here a key point is not about whether
you use your real name or not is that
you are anonymous to someone way over
across the world you don't care about
them they don't care about you and yet
online you can show a lot of hate
towards that person so ZTE is helping
build the fatherland card for Venezuela
that gives them like kind of like the
new-age coupon food stamps etc right
hey then we can track them when I was in
Singapore a few months back I was
talking to a colleague of mine and he
was wearing a device for tracking and I
said oh that's not a Fitbit no no no I
got this free I said from where he says
uh the Singaporean government like
really what for it's like well there's
this program where you basically like
get events if you do good exercise right
and then those achievements can be
turned into discounts whatever for
groceries so at every single moment in
time now the government knows where you
are but hey but it's good you get food
coop
right and legislation is slowly creeping
in right I mean in the UK you heard
about your thing was Amanda I'm rod with
someone that was talking about no you
can't have encryption encryption is evil
Australia said yeah we're gonna do it we
were inside the the back doors there and
allowed you know why do we even need an
encryption there's similar regulations
being passed in many countries in
Holland etcetera so it slowly slowly
creeping in in fact in Spain they've
just passed a new legislation that says
that the government can collect data not
the government sorry the political
parties are allowed to collect and
profile your social media information to
then target you
so essentially what everyone's saying is
wrong with what happened with Cambridge
analytical the Spanish government's like
yeah we're gonna pass a law to allow
that right I told you we always take
innovation to the next level and reports
are showing less and less freedom on the
Internet by the way everything I put
there's always a source so you can go
and look at it and of course there are
companies are caving in right I mean you
go to China now the great big Firewall
of China being works in China you know
there was a there was a show a comedian
the other day on Netflix that made the
rounds that all Netflix Saudi Arabia
government was angry with Netflix
because this was insulting I don't know
who so they censored that they're just
complying with the rules Apple in China
so if we go back to when we started and
we're asked how we're doing well let's
take a look censorship it's pretty much
their control is their big brother is
their information is entertainment
amusing ourselves to death is their
relevance is lost in irrelevance it's
their psychological manipulation is
their shallow forms of entertainment is
their so unfortunately Neil postman was
wrong both Huxley and Orwell were right
yeah coming back to welcome to the
Machine he says welcome my son welcome
to the Machine where have you been it's
all right we know where you've been
now roger waters was supposedly
referring to the music industry but hey
this is society right now what have you
dreamed it's alright we told you what to
dream and now al sorry AI wants to play
too
with big data right again in China there
is a camera literally everywhere
everywhere you can look there are
multiple cameras with facial recognition
there was a very good example of this I
think it was by the small documentary on
the BBC where some guy some journalist
said you know I'm gonna go and show this
picture of myself to the police
supposedly I'm a criminal they're gonna
capture me let's see how long it takes
them to capture me right
seven minutes it took before police
surrounded him in some random location
somewhere and all of that with a eye and
facial recognition manipulation and
billboards you know the piccola Daily
Lights right there was there was shut
off a few years ago and they've now
revamped they're beautiful but they're
context-sensitive data up to where their
etcetera all from a nice control panel
and supposedly you can now also based on
the people in the square adapt it right
so we're bringing targeted advertising
to physical world which is fantastic
right fake news fake video generators go
and say this that there's a this will
start up and I think it's called pick
screen or something like that upload the
picture some words blah blah blah makes
a fake night nice fake video for you now
today you can kind of tell and I might
be able to my mother might not be able
to tomorrow you might not be able to
tell anymore and all of this is
contributing to more things that are
maybe fake on the internet and of course
we all know that AI has issues right we
have the issue of bias google classifies
this into three selection bias the data
used to train the algorithm is biased to
begin with yes because here's an idea
we'll get a lie to make objective
decisions okay what should we feed it
data where do we get it from the world
is the world biased yes so you're
feeling it bias data no no no no no no
yes you are right you're feeding
historical data which is biased
interaction bias as I interact with the
algorithm the way the user you interacts
with it this promotes this bias
latent bias the algorithm incorrectly
corrects correlates data with gender
race income etc
examples of this where there has been
algorithms to say okay which one's the
more criminal which one should get the
more punishment guess what in this case
it was the gentleman on the right that
was more had more criminal activities
the computer said the one on the left
right interaction bias you'll note a yes
yeah oh this is the awesome AI that got
shot down to two minutes in it was
shouting hates and and Nazism and
everything no interaction bias Amazon
secretly scrubs an AI recruiting there
was showing bias against women
no really could it be that there is a
bias against women also in the world no
oh yeah right and then of course we've
got the naive implementations which is
like oh I'm gonna detect if you're
sarcastic based on emojis and the text
you right there okay good luck but of
course this even dates back to machine
learning right I had anyone read this
book on weapons of mass destruction this
is by a Cathy O'Neil that talks about
many time this is essentially data
science on big data and machine learning
has made that data science a little bit
more easier and more automated but it's
automatic data it's automatic data
mining essentially and it talks about
that there is no accountability for
algorithms that these algorithms are
developed in private and release the
public contracted by public
organizations with no accountability
towards them historical data that is
being used it's using it for historical
practices it's not suddenly we just cut
everything I said the other there you go
it's done right data points considered a
zip codes that you would think that
they're innocent but they're not
incorrectly correlating poverty with
race and gender etc it's wrong so and
this is essentially contributing to
increasing inequality and we're not even
talking about AI in the military and of
course I don't know much about AI but
when you have some people that
essentially do know somewhat about AI
and all of them whether you agree with
some of some people's perspectives or
not are raising concerns we should
actually be paying attention so in
summary and I'll try and make this very
short I know I'm running a few minutes
over time I apologize we're kind of
screwed okay thank you very much no
now the bad news is this is not an
episode of Black Mirror the good news is
that actually there isn't much in terms
of good news it really is like I'm not
gonna come and do an inspiring keynote
so what if anything can actually be done
what is this society I think there are
steps I think we could take the idea of
GDP our think it through properly before
stupidly into implementing it which is
what's happened with GDP are there are
initiatives Tim berners-lee has talked
about the freedom of the web trying to
join these efforts and trying to promote
this idea trying to raise awareness
certain regulations that can't be put in
place for data checks to to validate the
biases of that data to observe
transparency of algorithms this is again
something that Cathy O'Neill speaks
about ethics of the use of technology as
companies what can we do well I mean
some companies have even stopped
tracking targeted advertising and hey
it's not increasing revenues it's not
decreasing revenues as shot there are
some governments that are trying to
treat Internet as a fundamental right
Google is trying to introduce this
concept of fact-checking now I don't
know if this is gonna work or not but
their idea is that every snippet of
information will bring you some kind of
level of how much this fact has been
checked for you to decide whether this
can be true or not due to Google also
claims that they're going to change
their algorithms for YouTube now I don't
know about you but if you go to YouTube
now it is the most like every time you
look for something it takes you a little
bit more to the extreme a little bit
more to the more you know like oh let me
see ski ski boarding Oh ski boarding oh
top 10 hits of ski boarding next one is
like oh look at this person jumping off
a cliff with ski board and landing
correctly oh look at this one dying and
it's like going to the extreme every
time I actually get scared my kid
watches YouTube because he ends up in
some weird places the other day I ended
up in some weird crazy conspiracy thing
that the first comment was like I don't
know what I'm doing here and I'm like I
don't know what I'm doing here either
but that is it because it's about
engaging controversy conspiracies and
there hopefully saying that they're
moving away from this what can we do
what can we do
as individuals though well there are a
few things actually from a consumer
perspective we can stop putting all the
blame on technology we can stop having
headlines like saying social media is an
existence essential threat to our idea
of democracy no if it's not this
tomorrow will be something else we are
in existence your threat to our
democracy because of the way we are
acting because of the way we are sharing
information there are tools that make it
easier sure we have to be conscious of
that but it's about us at the end of the
day not everything we see is real
there's a lot of fake stuff on the
internet there is fake reviews yes about
the restaurant in England which was a
garden shed which made it to the top
restaurant in TripAdvisor
based on fake reviews so suddenly fake
reviews are okay but fake news is not
did we all what we all born and said we
will never generate fake news no right
fake comments fake businesses it's all
there it's all actually they're fake
politics it's there and of course fake
news but it also means that not
everything we disagree with is
necessarily fake news not everything we
disagree with we'll just say all these
are just some BOTS because sometimes it
may be that we need to contrast the
information we read sometimes we need to
understand that there are narratives at
play every media everything has their
own narrative has their own interests
everyone does
beware of one's own confirmation bias
and try proactively of breaking out of
bubbles I read a whole bunch of
different articles from different
newspapers yes I open up the Daily Mail
I open up the Telegraph I open up the
independent I open up the Guardian I
read all of these different things to
try and get a little bit of perspective
on all things in fact there's a paper
research that says reducing controversy
by connecting opposing views actually
helps positively I think Twitter's
picked up on this because it wants me to
follow Donald Trump and Alexandria and
at some point now and what I'm saying
here is applies to this talk as well
I've got a narrative for this talk I
want to show you some of the problems
that there are in society right now I've
shown and I've aligned every article
with what I want to say because I wanted
to make it coherent and make a flow I've
provided you with all the links if you
contrast that I've tried
- I've done my best to contrast and look
for multiple sources if I'm incorrect
please tell me about it
right this applies to this talk as well
as producers evaluates before handing
over data think about all of the
consequences analyzed before blindly
sharing think about the impact that this
will have if you don't have time to
investigate or contrast something don't
share it no one will care it's fine
evaluate the consequences of retweeting
or summarized think first in fact wired
had an article a year ago talking about
in the wake of an attack if you're
somewhere else in the world stop
retweeting because that might also
incite more panic and more fear and
exactly play into the hands of those
inciting terror these are things that we
need to think about and you know what be
a tad more cynical it's ok there was a
recent meme about how take a picture of
you 10 years ago in 10 years now someone
said actually this might be there trying
to get aging AI better yeah it's ok to
think about that just don't blindly do
everything that people tell you to do
and then last of all as technologists
educate the less tech-savvy tell your
fans tell your families about the
dangers of technology as technologies
that we're creating things move towards
a more sustainable business model right
where we don't have to solve people's
data where we don't get articles by the
dis lady nicely put that you know I want
to thank the VCS
because they've been subsidizing all of
the services I get yes but those VCS at
some point I'm gonna want to cash out
and what do they have pretty much only
data a nice example of this was a small
community where they created a smaller
community sustainable community with
honest ads just for a group of people in
the neighborhood and created a platform
otherwise known as if you remember the
old days listservs and BBS is for
specific people to specific communities
maybe the idea is that we don't need 6
billion of the people connected because
that's where the factor of anonymous
meet to you comes in I don't care about
your I'm not saying here I don't care
about the life of someone over there so
for me I don't care about the
consequences that it may have
I may have by criticizing them or
ranting or whatever maybe we don't need
the entire world connected in a single
platform called Facebook create
interfaces that favor privacy first move
away from dark UI patterns start to
think about protecting privacy this is a
awesome thing that is like a little
fungi that sits on your assistant that
filters out anything until you activate
data system and it all stays on the
Raspberry Pi nothing goes to the cloud
you see security of course never should
be an afterthought because things do get
hacked and most importantly account on
workflow device diversity diversity in
hiring there are 17 diversities in
everything we are technologists creating
technology for a diverse world where
people have different social incomes
they have different races they have
different genders they have different
orientations they have different things
we need to take this into account it
often feels like the software that we're
creating is catered to a single 1% of
the world and we can't do that by just
saying oh yeah we're thinking about
diversity only people that can think
about diversity is when you have a
diverse group of people teach discuss
and promote ethics think about things
that are wrong and it's not like I want
to you know pick on Facebook but it's
not like they make it really hard to
pick on them but it's like every other
day Facebook is in the news for
something that it's doing like duping
kids into spending money putting paying
teenagers to inspect his life fresh from
this morning
paying teenagers to install applications
to spy like this is not the way that we
want a connected society you know the
famous from Jurassic Park your scientist
was so preoccupied with whether or not
they could they didn't stop to think if
they should we actually should stop and
think once in a while because at the end
of the day as technologists beyond
producers consumers companies all of
this we've got the greatest
responsibility of all because we have a
hand in essentially everything
so to summarize whatever this machine
may be we're a cog in it now the
question is whether we can alter that
whether we can alter it
so that the machine moves
in a better direction and I believe and
I hope that we can thank you
[Applause]